would you like a home testing pit test
kits being handed out in kingston market
square
this borough of southwest london one of
more than 20 across england
where sharply rising infection rates
have prompted intensive
surge testing to identify and isolate
cases the steepest increase is among
young people and school children
groups which haven't yet been vaccinated
statistically
they're less likely to become seriously
ill but the concern is about
variance clearly we want to try and keep
the case rate as low as possible stop
having the virus spreading
because the more it spreads the more
likely you are to get more mutations and
more variants of the virus that may
actually
escape our vaccine we don't want to see
that
outside in the market square a busker
entertains the passers-by
with music venues closed for the past
year tim ot
has survived on loose change and a
part-time job
the latest postponement provokes a weary
shrug
the emotional response is i want to play
gigs again do you know what i mean i
want to go out and i want to do what i
love and
blah blah and the logical response is
like you know
back at the start of lockdown i was i
was criticizing the government for not
being tough enough
you know and people were dying and it
would be i'd be hypocritical now to say
like
come on let me play gigs you know i
honestly i don't know
june 21st have been dubbed freedom day
here in the uk
and postponing it has undoubtedly been a
really serious dilemma for this prime
minister with his libertarian reputation
and as the european summer has arrived
the appetite for mixing and socializing
has already increased but the advice
from his scientific advisors
was stark continue to unlock as planned
and hospital admissions would rapidly
reach the peak seen in the first wave
last year by being cautious now
we have the chance in the next four
weeks to save
many thousands of lives by vaccinating
millions more people and once the adults
of this company
have been overwhelmingly vaccinated
which is what we can achieve
in a short space of time we will be in a
far
stronger position to keep
hospitalizations down
to live with this disease and
to complete our cautious but
irreversible road map
to freedom more than 56 percent of uk
adults are now fully vaccinated
and extending restrictions into the
summer months is testing public patience
drifting may be enjoyable on the river
but not
in business or politics paul brennan al
jazeera
kingston uk